So one of the fossils that they began to find was this
a trilobite and that's actually
what Otto was drawing over here.
The trilobite began to emerge in the Cambrian
and the Silurian so they're very very old.
And Americans began to find these in the railroad cuts
that they were making through the rocks
of the United States. They began to
talk to people in England who were also
finding trilobites. And they began for the first time, now
again we take this for granted, but it was
not until the 1830s that people in Britain
and the Americas began to imagine
that those two areas of land had once been connected.
So this is a new geological understanding of
the past that is beginning to stretch
very far back in time.
So next time you see a trilobite be excited about it.
The Industrial Revolution is also important
because they are finding evidence of a time
in the past in Earth's history that was full
of what they now called and
this is a new term coined in the 1830s "fossil fuels."
Fossil fuels is a term that is coined
in the early 19th century precisely
during the deep time revolution.
They're cutting through the earth.
They're looking for fuel
to power the Industrial Revolution.
They find an era, a lost era, full of palm trees
from a time when the whole Earth
was like the Amazon. A kind of
what they called a "Carboniferous," an era of carbon.
And this was going to become,
here's another key word from this time period:
the "natural resource" that
would power the Industrial Revolution.
So the Industrial Revolution,
the cars, the trains,
are all part of the new ways of approaching the Earth
that helped get us to deep time.
Deep time is great, but it brings up
a bunch of new problems. And these are so interesting.
And I give them to you, not as me telling you
what to think, but as partners with me in thinking
about how difficult this is to think about.
So deep time presents a number of issues.
Let me just give you the first one.
The first thing is that deep time
is an inconceivable concept. Charles Darwin
is one of the many people in the 19th century
who thinks about deep time right
evolution has to happen over deep time.
And he says it is incomprehensively vast.
He is one of many others who look at the idea
of deep time, that the Earth is not 6,000
but maybe 10 million... 20 million...
4 billion years old... And says that may be so
but I cannot conceive of that.
So it's this startling new concept that
by its very nature is an inconceivable concept.
So this is  wonderful for historians like me
who like to imagine how people think about their world
to imagine a new idea that you cannot think about
is an absolutely extraordinary thing
that is very very fun for us to think about.
Deep Time also has a second problem with it
which is that it is existentially horrifying.
One thing we know about human beings
is that we like to be the center of the universe.
Nothing matters unless we are part of it.
Unless we are folded into our
own history of the universe.
And the history of the Earth
it's hard to understand why it should matter.
And deep time presents this problem
in a really palpable way.
The Bible ultimately is about human beings
and how you get from then to now.
And the Bible has at its very center
the sense that human beings are God's special creation.
Deep time does not have that assurance.
It removes humanity from the story of life
on Earth. From the story of Earth.
From the story of the cosmos.
You can have as many strata as you want
But if none of them contain human beings
and if none of them contain the things
that human beings are good at doing
which is having events. We have events.
We have events like this one and
events leave documents. They leave
traces in the historical record.
None of those are present in these strata.
So the strata present to people
who could not before have imagined
anything longer than a 6,000 year history
that was in a document
it was in the Bible.
The Bible had nothing to say about strata.
So this was very very unsettling.
A book in which we were not...
not just the main actors, but not actors at all.
So what do you do to fix this problem?
Well in the nineteenth century we see
a number of solutions emerging to this problem.
Which is to try to make the inconceivable concept
of deep time conceivable. Not only conceivable,
but as we saw with the slinky unwinding
of the Earth's history (in the thing
that you're gonna look at later on when you go home)
to make it beautiful, to make it relatable.
To make it in some ways part of our own humanity
When in fact we know deep down
inside that deep time
doesn't really have humanity necessarily as part of it.
So what do some of these images look like?
Some of these are going to be familiar to you.
But I hope that from now on you look at them as
the evidence of the birth of deep time.
So this is one of the many images to come out of some
of the Grand Canyon exploring expeditions
of the 1870s 1880s and 1890s.
This is William Henry Holmes'
painting of the Grand Canyon.
This is incredible, right? This is like strata central.
Looking down into the Grand Canyon you
see all of these layer cakes of time.
and look at these teeny tiny human beings.
They're totally insignificant in this larger canvas.
But it is so incredibly beautiful
that you don't care.
And it is so incredibly beautiful,
and I'm just giving you things to think about, right?
You don't have to agree with me just think about it.
Bear with me. It is so incredibly beautiful
that even though it is existentially horrifying
even though we as human beings are insignificant
we imagine that perhaps something like the deity
might be there because it is so transcendently beautiful
and it makes us think about eternity
in the way that people in the 18th century
and before thought about eternity.
So one way to think about deep time images
is as the secularization of the Judeo-Christian idea
of the cosmic eternity in the face of
the scientific revolutions of the 18th and 19th century.